look what just came in the mail this is
the brand-new Microsoft Surface Studio -
and this thing is incredible I had the
first version some of you guys may have
seen that unboxing and I've absolutely
loved it i've gamed I've done design
work on it I've edited videos on it this
model that we're about to unbox has the
seventh gen Core i7 processor one
terabyte solid state drive and 32 gigs
of ram so let's slice and dice this up
this knife is so sharp it's always so
shocking
are you ready it's got a little
illustration here that shows me that I
should probably lay it down so I'm not
doing it properly oh my gosh this thing
is so cool let's get you out of here
buddy let's free you from this prison
that they have put you in your styrofoam
in prison
they're amazing the song they're trying
to palette present justice move it out
come on oh my gosh I'm I'm so weak it's
actually not that heavy but it's so
awkward to try to hold it okay now we
got that out we'll get to you in a
second we'll see what else we've got in
here
oh sorry I don't know I got excited it's
like Christmas morning whenever you're
like go ahead and eat the Christmas tree
what presents did I get you try to
figure it out well we've got the power
cable I would have never guessed gosh
oops
ripped it look at that nice glossy
finish
I wanted to smell the paper and I give
myself paper dad don't touch my stylus
I like fine you get the joke don't touch
me say this what a great sound you hear
that should I just do a whole ASMR
channel okay okay you won't but someone
what I'm sure you've got the keyboard oh
wow
it just popped right out yeah right
oh that's nice it's just like it
magnetic I love service products like
Microsoft really has done such a great
job with these holds activate I can't
hold on to things I have a I have a I
have a problem so that's everything
that's in the Box a great sound in the
back here we've got four USB 3 port even
either net poor we have full we've got a
nice Thunderbolt port oh we've got a
nice USB C port and an SD card slot and
a headphone jack
[Applause]
what is that song
you gonna plug it in I almost stabbed
myself this play prisons off it is
system of it out what no absolutely not
play prison song no play prison song by
System of a Down
[Music]
I'm okay Wade loves this move it down
hey Siri stop playing before I get a
copyright strike she doesn't care about
my copyright strike stop playing I love
what you've done with the place
[Laughter]
oh you guys you come for the unboxing
and you stay for the tiny hat the big
house boots on and the dog's collar all
right
don't even ask questions it's like it's
fine okay Wow
the sheath was not on okay we're gonna
turn it on Oh what's happening I can't
see anything
is something happening it's honestly so
incredible hey and we'll have your PC
ready for all you plan to do I have the
same reaction every time I go to the
setup screen of your screen little
microphone if you need an assistive
screen reader press the windows control
and enter keys at the same time to turn
on narrator okay well I'm gonna set this
up and then I'll say eyes in a second
off Pedro let's see again
it is studio boxing may 2nd 2017 are we
doing an unboxing order we're doing I
just love that this is touchscreen like
this is so great I made the same joke
I was so worried that I was gonna wear
the same thing I should have checked I
wonder if I made into the other same
jokes I think I said the only get this
stylus poppin this couple the surface
style I think we decided the last time
it does not come with a surface dial so
I've been working really hard on this
illustration and I just am so excited
that today I get to show it to you so I
have a secret talent of drawing cars but
I don't like to finish them entirely I
just like I just it a little bit so
this is my drawing so I'm just gonna
finish this up color this in real nice
this is so incredible
I'm graffitiing all over this this is
what kind of a dial would be really cool
it's because you can use the dial to
just sort through colors and different
brushes so talented I Shepherd this out
you guys want this new my art how do I
make a new document oh my gosh look at
this this is so oops oh my gosh I closed
the book okay let me open up my
sketchbook so I would like for you guys
to subscribe did it really oh my gosh
there's no spellcheck on writing alright
well that's that I'm looking forward to
checking this out a little bit more I do
want to do a fortnight test of course
that's how I usually always test out
everything is well it handle fortnight
okay and I'm sure it will I played
overwatch on my last studio oh also by
the way when you flip it around
it's an eraser I have not written in
cursive and so long it feels weird
his his subscribe
oh it's like a plus like please his be
nice to me nice to me well let me know
what you guys think of this I'm such a
huge fan of all the surface stuff I
really love the studio line if any of
you guys have ever used this or if you
have what I would love to hear from you
leave me some comments below and let me
know what you think and what should I
try out next hey subscribe please
subscribe ok bye I'm so talented
[Music]